speaking of lawyers being sanctioned in  court we have a small update in one of  the kraken lawsuits in michigan in the  king vs whitmer suit in michigan  u.s district judge parker has a word for  the attorneys specifically in order that  states each attorney whose name appears  on any of plaintiff's pleadings or  briefs  shall be present at the motion hearing  set for july 6 2021  and that hearing specifically relates to  three different requests for sanctions  against sydney powell and the whole  kraken team  and that's an order from a judge that is  not a happy judge that is not an order  that says everyone is going to get out  fine now  we'll see what actually happens even  when sanctions are issued often there's  slaps on the wrist but this is not a  happy judge and we will see everyone  whose name appears on any of plaintiff's  briefs  in court